your goose would be cooked Republicans
would talk about nothing else hey guys
I'm off the grid for August but noted
television quote unquote journalist
slash Muppet Chris Hayes over at MSNBC
said this
one year ago today the inflation
reduction act the most significant piece
of climate legislation in U.S history
was signed into law and there's a case
to be made it's one of the most
significant and successful pieces of
legislation ever passed I mean just look
at the name and then look at what it did
in August of last year when the
inflation reduction Act was signed to
law inflation was 8.3 percent one year
later inflation is about 3.2 percent
inflation was reduced promises made
promise is kept now I can hear all of
you macroeconomics Buffs out there
yelling at your TVs the IRA was a clean
energy infrastructure bill with some uh
drug prescription pricing too dropping
inflation had more to do with the easing
of the supply chain issues from covet
and the decline in oil prices as markets
came back after the invasion of Ukraine
and the raid hike from the FED yes
that's all true
the way politics works is the president
gets all the blame when the economy is
bad so they get to take the credit when
the economy is improving
so the Democrats have this kind of
stroke of Genius last summer when they
were loggerheads with West Virginia
Democratic senator Joe manchin the
deciding vote who was wavering on voting
for the ACT because he was concerned
about additional spending and what it
would mean for inflation so they renamed
their spending Bill the inflation
reduction act at the time that was seen
as a kind of cheeky dig at Republicans
but it worked that decision has borne
both substantive and political dividends
I mean think about it this way if it
were a Republican president who signed a
bill called the inflation reduction act
and then inflation dropped by five
points in one year it would be all they
ever talked about
so President Biden any other Democrat in
politics some free advice
I understand you're kind of reluctant to
bring up inflation when it's still a
little higher than everyone would like
to be but 3.2 percent is a lot less than
8.3 percent everyone knows that
go out and tell everyone we passed the
inflation reduction act and over the
next year inflation plummeted
think about it this way if you pass the
inflation reduction act and inflation
had got up Five Points your goose would
be cooked Republicans would talk about
nothing else we passed the inflation
reduction act and inflation plummeted it
even fits on a bumper sticker